elle était professeur de musique lui
porter dentiste pendant dix ans judith
et felipe ont vécu le bonheur quasi
parfait à santa marta une petite station
balnéaire des caraïbes colombienne avec
leurs deux enfants marina et felipe
david le couple faisait partie de l'une
des familles les plus influentes de la
région de santa marta
un matin de décembre 2006 felipe laura
ce n'est qu'au quitte son cabinet
d'orthodontie dans le centre médical
perla del caribe vers sa voiture
la méthode est typiquement colombienne
deux hommes à moto
l'âme et d'un pistolet lui tire trois
coups de feu dans la nuit à bout portant
felipe race meurt sur le coup et
s'effondre à l'intérieur de sa voiture
[Musique]
judith brassard les pousses de felipe
est à montréal avec les enfants au
moment du meurtre
elle apprend la nouvelle au téléphone de
sa belle-mère en colombie a décidé en
dessous et felipe je dis non non je
n'arrêtais pas de créer deux ans après
la mort tragique de son mari judith
brassard est arrêté condamné et
incarcéré dans une prison colombienne
pour avoir commandé son meurtre pourtant
dans ce plaidoyer déposés en cour
suprême
l'embout de semaine de la justice
colombienne demandait la libération de
judith brassard
pour tenter de comprendre cette
condamnation nous avons obtenu
l'autorisation de rencontrer judith
brassard dans sa prison de santa marta
nous avons aussi rencontré des témoins
qui n'ont jamais été entendues lors du
procès nous avons même rencontré l'un
des tueurs ce qu'ils disent tous c'est
que judith brassard n'a pas tué son mari
fait du vélo face
témoignage exclu absence de preuves
judith brassard
at elle eu droit à un procès juste et
équitable la question se pose
[Musique]
québec le 26 mai 1993
c'est un longue fin de semaine mois de
mai donc il ya un minivan qui s'est
stationné et je voyais que le chauffeur
avait comme une map
il est tombé l'amap de toutes les coupes
et donc j'ai frappé à la porte puis j'ai
arrêté est ce que je peux vous aider
ils sont plusieurs étudiants latino mais
judith n'a d'yeux que pour felipe lauras
27 ans un étudiant en orthodontie à
l'université mexico judith et felipe
passe l'été ensemble à québec puis au
mexique en attendant la reprise des
études de felipe ces textes on a passé
deux mois on se voyait tous les jours
c'était vraiment leur le père de mes
enfants c'est vraiment l'automne venu
judith est de retour au québec
diplômé en musique à l'université laval
elle a accepté un poste d'enseignante
dans un collège privé de montréal mais
elle rêve d'une carrière sur scène et
elle monte son premier spectacle solo
nos maux
même de loin l'intense roman d'amour
avec felipe continuent elles remettent
en cause son projet de carrière
on était séparés physiquement dans ce
cas-là l'internet c'est peut-être pas
pour tout le monde donc que c'était
téléphone lettres puis à un moment donné
lundi bon c'est fini ou on se marie le
mariage a lieu à la chapelle notre dame
de la victoire à québec le 6 ou 1994
[Musique]
qui prend mari prend pays quelques
semaines plus tard judith entame une
nouvelle vie à santa marta en colombie
avec l'homme de sa vie felipe rojas
felipe l'amour de même il traite être
pour le mondial il n'y avait pas de
différences sociales qui mois par mois
vous pourrez être canadienne de santa
marta ya beaucoup de différences
sociales
les différences sociales qui ne sont pas
toujours faciles à surmonter pour une
étrangère comme judith qui vit au sein
d'une famille influente
le beau-père ou alors à c'est un major
de l'armée à la retraite
les familles alors assez celle de la
belle mère il va une éco sont de
vieilles souches en ville les familles
bien branché dans toutes les
institutions sociales politiques et
juridiques de santa marta
malgré ces différences judith s'intègre
assez rapidement elle enseigne la
musique o'shea collège bilingue de santa
marta
pendant que felipe développe sa pratique
d'orthodontie il fonde une famille deux
enfants mariana et felipe david la vie
de famille est intense les frères soeurs
et même les cousins sont omniprésents au
fil du temps le couple prospects il
achète un condo dans un chic quartier de
santa marta tout près des beaux-parents
et fréquente les meilleurs clubs et
associations de la région
c'était une personne quelqu'un y arriver
et prenez la tension pour pour ces jo
s'efface c'est ce était beau d'ailleurs
c'était physiquement très beau séducteur
ou pas séducteur felipe mais volage en
tout cas judith apprendra grâce à une
facture de téléphone qu'il la trompait
déjà lors de sa première grossesse
il appelait souvent une autre femme j'ai
jamais souffert pour pour les amendes de
mon mari j'ai su qu'il y avait
une femme qu'il l'appelait j'ai cherché
le nom de cette équipe c'est la seule
chose que j'ai fait pour avant tout mon
mariage
le reste du temps felipe voulait
toujours chez la maison je n'ai jamais
souffert pour ça mais le climat
politique en colombie pèse plus lourd
sur le couple que les indiscrétions de
felipe depuis 50 ans une guerre civile
ravage la colombe pour se protéger de la
guérilla des farc les forces armées
révolutionnaires colombiennes
les familles puissantes ont formé des
groupes d'autodéfense paramilitaires qui
finissent par se livrer au banditisme et
au trafic de drogue
[Musique]
dans cette époque là il y avait beaucoup
de pêche miraculeuse en colombie c'est à
dire qu'ils ne puissent pas de symptômes
apparemment qui ils peuvent arrêter qui
demande finement de l'argent ce n'est
jamais arrivé mais c'était très courante
dans les années 80 18 99 2000 donc je
disais felipe pourquoi on va porter vos
canada en juin 2001 judith obtient un
poste d'enseignante à windsor
felipe doit venir la rejoindre plus tard
les enfants s'adaptent mal ça n'a pas
marché
raymond brassard et à windsor pour aider
sa fille avec les enfants felipe mais
milk and ainsi que de sa tournée là-bas
quant à nice sont tombés là bas cela
dérangeait beaucoup lui pour pourquoi
vous savez pourquoi il aimait 18 femmes
en inde de mariage
j'ai décidé de revenir malgré qu'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord
c'est là qu'on a commencé à avoir des
problèmes dont qu' il ya quelque chose
le club au marché les quelque chose qui
s'est brisée judith reprend sa vie à
santa marta
elle retrouve son travail au collège
bilingue au cours des cinq années
suivantes elle produit des spectacles et
des comédies musicales avec ses
étudiants elle enregistre même un cd son
premier intitulé hammam et aime moi
[Musique]
s'adresse-t-elle à felipe en tout cas
depuis le retour de windsor les
relations ne sont pas bonnes ce qui mène
judith à être infidèle à son tour même
si on veut garder les apparences d'une
vie familiale heureuse
le couple bas de laine juin 2006 judith
et les enfants quittent santa marta
prétextant des vacances au québec rendu
à montréal elles entament des procédures
de divorce
son avocat lui fait comprendre qu'il
n'ya pas d'entente entre le canada et la
colombie en ce qui concerne la
séparation de biens familiaux
judith se rend donc à miami où elle vide
le compte de banques conjointe de ces
119 me dollars en imitant la signature
de felipe puis elle appelle sa
domestique catherine pris très à santa
marta pour qu'elle lui envoie ses bijoux
à la fin août 2006 la cour familiale du
québec à nu l'union de judith brassard
et de felipe lauras elle accorde à
judith la garde temporaire des enfants
mais felipe contre attaque
il accuse judith d'enlèvement et
demandent le retour immédiat des enfants
le tribunal lui donne gain de cause
marianne à 11 ans et felipe david 9 ans
sont colombien ils doivent retourner
dans leur pays
on dirait quand j'ai su vraiment qu'il
fallait que je retourne les enfants je
dirais qu est ce que j'ai fait je suis
parti dans mon pays a loué des femmes ma
famille c'est juste que je suis parti
trop loin
partout au canada danse et c'est devenu
tout est devenu plus grave à cause de ça
le 4 décembre judith confirme par
courriel le retour des enfants en
colombie à la fin du mois puis lé dépose
à l'école et se rend au travail au
collège loyola
le même jour presque à la même heure
felipe leur race n'est qu est abattu en
pleine rue devant sa clinique à santa
marta
judith décidé de précipiter son retour
pour la colombie mais avant elle doit
parler aux enfants felipe david arrêtait
pas de crier pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
mon père pourquoi tu mets rien n'a rien
dit mais rihanna elle avait deux langues
puis atteint leurs liens du rien rien
rien jeudi dernier puis je pleurais pas
c'était un choc total pour moi
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'une fois arrivée à santa
marta au salon mortuaire que la petite
marianne à crac'h
je visais cas il faudrait que j'aille
puis que je vois que celui mais oui je
fait ça puis après ça j'ai plat et
l'enterrement ait lieu le jour suivant
c'est alors que judith prend une autre
décision qu'elle ne tardera pas à
regretter
donc c'est le cas chez des sondes rester
en colombie pas parce que c'était moi
qui voulait ça j'étais venu avec ma
famille dans mon pays mais je les fais
comme comme un sacrifice dont comme pour
payer que j'avais j'avais fait quelque
chose de pas correct a séparé mes
enfants de leur faire puis en plus il y
est décédé mais son père et mon passage
un mauvais pressentiment je voulais pas
qu'un te mana bat à nouveau parce
qu'elle avait entrepris les procédures
de dimension mais elle n'avait pas l'air
de se méfier mais vous non on en est là
c'est une bonne personne ne s'en plaint
pas de mal à une mouche
très vite après l'enterrement selon
judith son beau-frère hausse et raphaël
lui conseille de toucher les assurances
vie 215 milles dollars de felipe elle
demande à rosser raphaël dans l'investir
30000 pour les enfants avec le reste
elle s'achète une assurance-vie en
nommant les enfants comme bénéficiaire
[Musique]
en décidant de rester vivre en colombie
judith est loin de se douter que ces
actions de la dernière année
l'encaissement des assurances vie
l'enlèvement de ces enfants la
récupération de ces bijoux et le retrait
de l'argent à la banque de miami et même
son infidélité
tout ça servirait d'arguments plus tard
pour la condamner
oh
[Musique]
après l'enterrement de felipe judith
brassard décide de rester à santa marta
en colombie pour que ses enfants soient
à proximité de leurs grands parents
mais l'ambiance n'est pas très agréable
ce n'est pas une mauvaise ambiance je
n'étais pas une bonne ambiance avec
beaucoup de tristesse lui ne sait
peut-être tout le monde demande n'en
revenais pas personne savait qu est ce
qui s'était passé
judith ne le savait pas mais la
chronique d'une condamnation annoncée
c'est la formule de son avocat au procès
la machination avait commencé sa
belle-soeur il va martal aqueuse qu'elle
s'acharne insinué de façon haineuse que
judith et la responsable du meurtre de
philippe et c'est là qu'a malienne c'est
ça la can c'est à cause de l'argent qu'à
la crise et la canadienne s'est donc
c'est ça tout de suite et elle qui écrit
et ça mais personnes me disaient de
longs mois parce qu'ils enquêtent sur
l'assassinât de felipe lauras ne
progresse pas jusqu'à ce que la police
finit ce n'est arrêtée ce jeune homme
gabriel ramires paulo l'un des tueurs
son complice qui conduisait la moto l'a
dénoncé dans une entrevue exclusive
il explique pour la première fois la
caméra comment il a tué froidement
felipe leur race ce matin de décembre
j'ai vu la voiture de monsieur felipe et
je me suis approché lorsqu'il
s'apprêtait à monter dans la voiture je
me suis approché davantage
et je les tire est trois fois les deux
tueurs à vous ils ont été engagés par un
ancien paramilitaire giorno sorriaux qui
se trouve être le conjoint de la
domestique de judith catherine quitter
tous les quatre sont reconnus coupables
du meurtre de felipe lauras et condamnés
à de lourdes peines de prison
reste maintenant à trouver celui ou
celle qui a commandé l'assassinât
plusieurs pistes se présentent aux
enquêteurs dans un tout autre procès un
témoin se fait interroger sur le cas de
ferries p ô race c'est un cas de
vengeance dit il l'orthodontiste aurait
eu une relation amoureuse avec la femme
d'un commandant paramilitaires crime
passionnel
[Applaudissements]
mais le plus troublant encore c'est la
version non corroborée de l'un des
tueurs
ramires paulo juan miguel il avait une
camionnette blanche
c'est un chirurgien un médecin quelques
jours après l'assassinât en se rendant
chez john ossorio pour se faire payer
gabriel ramirez paulo voit le frère de
felipe juan miguel dans une camionnette
blanche
j'ai vu la camionnette devant la maison
de soyaux le frère de felipe lui a remis
un paquet c'était le solde de l'argent
pour le meurtre ramires paulo dit que
ses complices lui confirme que c'est
bien le frère qui a commandé et payé le
meurtre je lui ai dit pourquoi tu ne
m'en a pas parlé il m'a répondu c'est
son frère qu'il a fait tuer à son procès
ramires paulo veut tout révélé mais il
affirme qu'on l'a forcé à garder le
silence sous menace d'alourdir sa peine
ces témoignages sont ils véridique on ne
le saura jamais car ces pistes n'ont pas
été explorées par la fiscale il ya les
enquêteurs du bureau du procureur
général
c'est comme s'il avait déjà décidé que
c'est judith qui avait commandité le
meurtre de son mari
ils l'ont placé sous écoute électronique
ont cherché à savoir si elle tenterait
de communiquer avec les assassins ça n'a
rien donné
[Musique]
l'été 2008 julie pas en vacances au
canada avec les enfants elle sait qu'à
son retour était attendu pour une
rencontre avec les enquêteurs
elle est craintif ça lui fait part ce
train quand elle sent quelque chose
elle n'avait pas le goût de retourner
mais elle aurait pu rester ici elle
aurait pu s qu'elle aurait dû rester ici
oui mais tu es seulement vacances à son
retour judith seront à la convocation
des enquêteurs
après l'avoir nié lors de l' enquête
préliminaire elle avoue avoir falsifié
la signature de son mari pour retirer
l'argent du compte de banque de miami
on lui demande si elle soupçonne
quelqu'un du meurtre de son mari et elle
donne les noms qui court sur toutes les
lèvres à santa marta sa domestique
catherine piquet et son mari le para
militaires john ossorio le couple réagi
lui rendre la pareille et l'accuse
formellement de leur avoir commandé et
payé le meurtre de son mari felipe
selon ossorio judith lui aurait donné
l'ordre de tuer felipe par téléphone
pendant qu'elle était à l'extérieur du
pays sur la foi de ces deux témoignages
judith brassard et a été le 27 août 2008
pour le meurtre de son mari felipe lopes
quand ils m'ont arrêté je comprenais
rien j'avais peur que ce qui est arrivé
ils ont dit non il ya quelqu'un qui a
faim témoignage pour collaborer avec la
justice mais je dis que ce soit
n'importe qui c'est dément sens parce
que j'ai encore fait ça
[Musique]
le 27 août 2008 basé sur les témoignages
de johno sorriaux et de catherine pitre
et les agents de la fiscalité
les enquêteurs du bureau du procureur
général se rend au collège bilingue de
santa marta pour arrêter jeudi brassard
au canada ses parents sont
catastrophiques c'est étrange pour moi
les quinze premiers jours je la remets
poche mangin porcin chaque tu
[Musique]
près de braïla
judith et placé en détention préventive
dans la prison de santa marta la même
prison qui renferme le tueur gabriel
ramires paulo et celui qui l'a recruté
jornod soleil dans la section des femmes
judith tombe face à face avec une autre
détenue son ancienne domestique
catherine pitre et je me suis approché
j'écoute site un quart de mer
j'ai toujours dit la vérité dit la
vérité parce que mes enfants n'ont pas
de parent et ont pas de mal c'est pas
juste
j'ai rien fait il sait puis coup de
théâtre
sa domestique catherine pitre et se
rétracte ghana supporter cela la
pression je ne supportais plus la
pression c'était injuste
elle a été accusée de quelque chose
qu'elle n'a pas fait
et il n'y avait pas moyen de pointer à
la retraite quand je me suis rendu
compte des gestes de soyaux ça m'a fait
mal de l'avant en prison à cause de nous
à cause de lui
jeauneau soyaux qui n'a pas accepté de
nous rencontrer se rétracte également il
affirme que felipe a été tué parce qu'il
blanchit c'est de l'argent aux liées au
trafic de la drogue et qu'il devait cent
mille dollars à des chefs paramilitaires
ossorio refuse de dévoiler les noms de
peur de se faire tuer
la justice colombienne écartera c'est de
rétractation pourtant spectaculaire et
qui innocente et judith
on n'a jamais cru que rend pas c'est
parce que c'est rétracter ce toriola il
dit j'ai fait un faux témoignage
ll est pas coupable henry à son mari me
dit ben coudon c'est mon sens ils vont
la faire sortir mais non
avril 2009 début du procès de judith
brassard à santa marta
la journaliste ginette la marche de
radio-canada parvient à lui arracher
quelques paroles alors qu'elle se dirige
vers la salle d'audience est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que j'allais pouvoir
dans un procès juste et a apparemment le
juge s'est toujours bien en face de tout
le monde sauf que par en dessous de
choses d'influencé suffit à l'extérieur
les amis de judith manifeste mais ils
sont rapidement découragé
ha mais ça un ami de judith accuse la
famille d'intimidation
on sentait l'agression de la famille il
ne pointait du doigt comme ça et vous
m'avez demandé pourquoi le mouvement
s'est effritée en colombie quand on te
pointe du doigt tu te retrouves avec la
gorge tranchée
dans la salle d'audience l'atmosphère
est aussi très tendu ba tan dung so pour
le familiarise ken hawk est liée à la
présidentielle ont prétendu la famille
ne voulait pas de journalistes dans la
salle d'audience et lomé où elle a
demandé aux juges de sortir les membres
des médias la police de tours a cappella
le juge a accepté
judith est défendu par l'avocat gustavo
gonzalez ramos lui aussi sans le poids
de la famille sur tout le processus
judiciaire
[Musique]
c'est une famille puissante qui vit une
énorme tristesse une grande douleur
elle veut se venger à n'importe quel
prix
la stratégie du procureur repose sur le
premier témoignage accusatoire de john
ossorio osorio aurait proposé d'aider
judith avec ses problèmes de couple en
faisant peur à felipe ou en éliminant au
choix cette rencontre aurait eu lieu à
santa marta en juillet 2006 sauf que
judith n'était plus à santa marta au
mois de juillet
pro sorriaux dit qu'il a accepté
d'orchestrés l'assassinât de felipe pour
la somme de 4000 $ après avoir parlé à
judith sur son cellulaire de la
compagnie aulas alors qu'elle était à
l'extérieur du pays sauf que le
cellulaire colombien de judith était
resté à santa marta osorio dit qu'il a
ordonné la mort de philippe et après
avoir reçu le signal de judith
lorsqu'elle était au panama judith n'a
jamais mis les pieds au panama
ces incohérences ne semble pas déranger
les représentants de la justice
colombienne
pas plus que la démonstration par
l'avocate judith qu'il n'y a eu aucune
communication téléphonique entre ossorio
et judith rejetée par le juge qui
invoque une erreur de procédure existe
et al ghul lequel court dit il n'y a
aucune preuve que judith et contacté un
tueur à gages par téléphone par internet
ou par n'importe quel autre moyen
alors la grande question c'est comment
judith aurait-elle pu ordonner
l'exécution par télépathie et gloser
l'apartheid
lorsque le procureur a fait sa
présentation on se serait cru au cirque
ça avait une allure folklorique
la représentante de la fiscalisation
nettoyaient les ongles on a même pris
une photo d'elle qui dormait pendant
l'audience
la finale incroyable écrit
pas de preuves de communication avec
john o soyaux pas de preuves de paiement
non plus selon lui
j'ai dit non tu veux quand je revenais
du canada jouets de payer leur traque
redit oui l art à crédit ce qui est dit
c'étaient tous des mensonges parce que
techniquement c'est prouvé que j y ai
pas téléphoné que j'ai pas parlé avec
lui qu il faisait n'importe quoi tout ce
temps martin suit le procès
attentivement la presse unanime s'en
tient à la version officielle
même avant d'être condamné judith
brassard surnommée la veuve noire est en
forme il termine un terreau propice à la
famille est intervenu auprès des
propriétaires des médias qui est scellé
viella on voulait que les reportages sur
le procès démontre que judith brassard
était coupable de l'homicide et
l'alimentaire comme on coule pas les
messieurs
preuves et témoignages rejetée expulsion
des journalistes de la salle d'audience
pression de la famille sur les amis de
l'accusé et sur les propriétaires des
médias locaux un procès pour le moins
confus juste et équitable
la question se pose quel projet cho le
procès n'avait aucun fondement rationnel
la trachée l'épreuve la justice il on a
mis tout ça de côté pour se reposer sur
la haine
on a tourné le dos aux preuves d'aldo
les résultats une grande injustice
contre judith brassard contre audi place
le procès dure neuf l'ombre lorsque le
verdict tombe
il est terrible elle 28 ans de prison et
2 millions de dollars en réparations à
la famille du défunt des 200 km a
parfois on était convaincu qu'elle
allait sortir
on a même apporté du vin et des fleurs
[Musique]
c'est comme ça
moi je ne peux pas croire que la marque
fait était trop il centre au jeu peu
comment dire ça en français mais elle
était trop innocent peau pour faire
quelque chose comme ça jamais pu penser
la fin tu n'as jamais douté non jamais
jamais jamais la famille aura ce n'est
qu'au n'a pas voulu participer à notre
enquête à sa place à la déléguée son
avocat ivan gonzalez amado évidemment
progrès ce qui permettait predica la
culpabilité
il ya suffisamment de preuves pour
confirmer la culpabilité de judith
brassard mission il est certain que ces
preuves peuvent offrir des hypothèses
divergentes mais si on examine l'analyse
faite par les représentants de la
justice
et si on tient compte des lois
colombienne on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas
eu de condamnation injuste est tombé
hockey en arizona qu'on déguste
judith accuse le coup difficilement mais
est-ce que vous me direz vous avez été
piégé par la famille je ne sais pas est
ce que vous diriez vous avez été piégé
mais piégé dans un sens si j'avais
vraiment voulu repartir au canada je
l'avais fait donc j'ai voulu rester
c'est mais j'ai jamais pensé qu'il pense
et soeurs il est trop tard pour des
regrets mais tout n'est pas perdu il
reste des recours et de l'espoir à la
cour d'appel
[Musique]
judith est en prison depuis près de six
ans dans des conditions qui ne sont pas
faciles
on est presque 140 femmes dans un
endroit où devrait avoir 5 ans donc
personnellement dans ma cellule ou dans
ma chambre c'est plus comme une chance
on est cinq son autorisation de visiter
la cellule de judith nous avons demandé
à une des détenus de prendre des images
avec un cellulaire comme les cinq
personnes trois qui ont des lignes moi
j'ai un hymne est ce parce que ça fait
longtemps que je suis et en a deux qui
sont sur le plancher avec avec un
matelas quand même et c'est
difficilement promiscuité oui c'est sûr
pour apprendre à tolérer pour apprendre
à partager pour avoir peut être très
toujours à donner la main à quelqu'un
parce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
besoins si je me sens privilégié
personnellement pour aider à combler ses
besoins judith se rend utile
elle donne des cours d'anglais aux
détenus et aux personnels de la prison
[Musique]
je lui dis tu peux voir ses enfants une
heure seulement par semaine c'est ce
qu'il ya plus difficile
l'absence de ma mère c'est toujours de
je pense qu'à la vérité dans les les
étapes comme dans les années que quand
on avait besoin d'elle on a toujours
besoin d'elle mais dans les années qui
était quand même présent 14 15 on était
comme toujours
moi par exemple je pleurais tout le
temps je sais tout le temps comme ça
puis à savais pas ce que je voulais je
voulais pas la faire pleurer puis tout
ça mais c'était 2
[Musique]
ça
pour aider à passer le temps judith
organisé un groupe de chant
kelly
judith semble bien supporté mais ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas pendant qu'elle
attendait le verdict du juge de la cour
de première instance elle a subi des
menaces d'extorsion cdd personne qui
aura fait jusqu'ici et hallyday le jeu
je te fais dire que ce tueur est en voie
vingt mille dollars
tu vas être libérés alors qu'est-ce que
je répondais je n'ai je ne crois pas
autre tentative de corruption
après le procès le frère de la victime
rose et la file à lauras aurait tenté de
soudoyer la directrice de la prison pour
qu'elles transfèrent judith loin de
santa marta
il voulait que je lui accorde une faveur
je voulais que je la transfert dans une
prison à sécurité maximum pour qu'elle
n'ait plus de contacts avec ses enfants
je lui dis je suis une mère je fils du
même âge que celui de madame brassard ne
comptez pas sur moi
sandra calero perd son emploi
judith et transféré près de cali à 1200
km au sud de santa marta
elle a dû se battre et ses enfants aussi
pour revenir
oh
[Musique]
témoignages semblables à la prison de
matériel
[Musique]
adriano sanchez comme à sète un chef
paramilitaire bien connu il dit que rose
et raphaël rojas son ancienne amie et
collègue de l'école d'architecturé
aurait aussi tenté de le soudoyer
bourgoin mais c'est dans la boîte
il voulait que je demande au jeune homme
qui a commis le meurtre d'accuser judith
je lui ai dit non
j'aurais pu témoigner non datée mondiaux
mais le juge ne voulait pas l'avocat de
judith voulait présenter mon témoignage
comme preuve tu rates en des termes on
provoquera conseillers nous laisse le
juge a refusé
il n'y avait rien à faire et on a
condamné jeudi
l'autre frère de felipe juan miguel
horace aurait lui aussi offert de
l'argent à l'un des tueurs pour qu'ils
inculquent judith brassard lui dit non
je ne céderai pas il m'a répondu si tu
ne collabore pas je vais te tuer les
jours où tu sortiras prison je lui ai
dit je t'attendrai pour l'avocat de la
famille ces accusations sont insensées
les frères horace n'ont pas tenté de
manipuler la preuve
les preuves sont administrés et présenté
par la fiscalité
elles ne sont pas présentées ni orienté
par la famille la fiscale y en a qui est
chargé d'enquêter et le juge sont
complètement et dépendant de la famille
le 20 octobre 2010 la condamnation de
judith est confirmée par la cour d'appel
du district de santa marta énorme
déception une fois de plus convaincus
d'une grande injustice judith brassard
et sa famille ont demandé très tôt
l'aide du gouvernement canadien
judeh a demandé d'avoir quelqu'un ou
procès à chaque fois de l'ambassade de
bogota canadienne en bretagne a envoyé
quelqu'un jamais on eu des échos de sang
jamais on n'a rien eu un rap en tout ça
je les fais une plainte écrite en deux
volets au mois de mai pilote au mois de
novembre 2010 jamais entendu parler du
vin de temps jamais jamais jamais
si vous demandez quelque chose au bout
de la corde mais jamais ô vous ait les
documents du ministère des affaires
étrangères du canada confirme que
l'ambassade canadienne à bogota a envoyé
une observatrice à la plupart des
audiences et qu'elle s'assurerait de
conditions de détention convenable mais
pas question pour le canada de
s'immiscer dans les procédures
judiciaires de la colombie tant que les
recours judiciaires n'ont pas été
épuisées c'est la politique officielle
l'ambassade canadienne également à
demander une révision du procès par le
conseil de la magistrature il y a eu
enquête mais elle n'a donné aucun
résultat
[Musique]
bogota le coeur du quartier historique
la cour suprême s'apprête à réviser la
cause de judith brassard
le ministère public de la colombie c'est
à dire l'embout de ce mal de la justice
colombienne
donc l'état colombien lui-même produit
un document choc le ministère soulève
l'absence totale de preuves matérielles
ils remettent en cause la crédibilité
accordée par le tribunal aux
déclarations de john ossorio il soulève
que la preuve démontre que judith
brassard n'est pas allé au panama qu'il
était impossible qu'elle ait utilisé son
cellulaire colombien puisqu'il était
resté à santa marta et que les registres
des communications indique qu'aux rios
n'a pas reçu d'appel de judith aux dates
spécifiées dans son témoignage
pour le ministère il est clair que le
récit de john au sérieux ne correspond
pas à la réalité est qu'il faut
appliquer le principe du doute
raisonnable
il demande à la cour suprême de casser
la sentence et d'acquitter judith
brassard
judith les amis et la famille sont ravis
qu'ils sont sûrs de gagner
mais lorsque la bombe explose personne
ne veut y croire les juges de la cour
suprême confirme les décisions des deux
première instance
28 ans de prison pour meurtre et deux
millions de dollars en réparations la
famille du défunt
les juges disent que judith était la
seule personne qui a eu de sérieux
problèmes avec la victime et qu'elle
était la seule personne qui aurait pu
bénéficier de sa mort quand tu penses
qu'il ya eu la corruption tout le temps
jusqu'à suprême de la colombie c'est le
temps de la corruption
j'ai pensé à étudier de droite pour mais
pour ça mais pour la corruption gpo fait
il manque un morceau à l'histoire
à quelques pas et c'est quelque chose
qu'on veut étouffer
c'est ce écoute si la cour suprême était
capable de reconfirmé ma sentence qui
est basé sur rien de l'ère des
suppositions de ce que j'ai fait quand
je me suis séparée de ce que j'ai fait
quand felipe et aimant omv sur aucune
autre preuve on ne saura peut-être
jamais qui a commandé la mort de felipe
laura ce n'est qu'au avec tant de pistes
inexplorées des témoignages
contradictoires une chose reste certaine
il n'a pas été prouvé hors de tout doute
que judith brassard est responsable du
meurtre de son mari n'allait pas arrêter
de vous battre pour la faire libérer
j'imagine jamais jamais jamais tout ce
qui est possible de faire ce qu'on sait
qu'elle est innocente
pour la fille de judy de mariana pas
question de laisser tomber sa mère de la
vérité ça va ça va sortir un jour tout
ce que se fait ici ce pays
ce que je crois
sinon c'est moi qui va qui vaut faire ça
tu vas trouver tu veux chercher tu veux
trouver qui a fait ça
théoriquement judith brassard est épuisé
tous ses recours juridiques en colombie
tout ce qui lui reste c'est l'opinion
publique est peut-être la justice
internationale